so I'm going to talk to you a little bit
about the AI in society program and this
is very much reflective it's a portion
of the pan-canadian AI strategy and it
was very clear as the community of AI
scientists got together and we started
to talk about the strategy and what
Canada needed to do that it was going to
be essentially important from the very
earliest days of the work we were going
to do together to have a component of
the strategy focused on the societal and
ethical ethical implications of AI so
really centering the technology in the
world around us and so we were all
extremely happy when the Government of
Canada allocated some funding within the
strategy to catalyze interdisciplinary
intersectional and cross-sectoral groups
coming together across borders to
explore the opportunities and challenges
that AI poses to society so we brought
together experts from across those
sectors academia industry law ethics and
government and we wanted to give them
some time to engage in some meaningful
discussions about both the opportunities
and challenges that AI poses to society
hope I went the wrong way just a little
bit about what we've done in the last
two years so we've engaged with 300 over
300 individuals have come together
through either workshops or labs that
we've been running we've been partnered
with a number of organizations
representing over 20 countries and 40
different disciplines and sectors coming
together so it's really been a busy and
very interesting time and there's two
areas of activity predominantly that
we've been focusing on so the first were
a series of what we called AI and
society research workshops we launched
our first call in the spring of 2018 and
have been holding workshops ever since
we will hold 15 before we finish up
that's first two rounds and the second
round we were very very pleased to be
working both with CNN
in in France and also UK research and
innovation to really extend the
engagement beyond beyond Canada and the
countries that we were connected to to
ensure that we also had leadership from
across both France and and the UK and so
each of the workshops as I said is
international
it had to be interdisciplinary and it
had to engage with people who were
putting these ideas into practice
whether they were in policy in
technology or in civil society and then
each workshop was also required to
produce with it a technical publication
that was public facing and useful to
policymakers and practitioners moving
forward so here's a list of the
proposals that were successful in our
two calls all the way from our very
first workshop which was looking at
indigenous protocol and AI and the
epistemologies and ways of understanding
culture and history that come out of our
indigenous communities and what AI can
do for them and also what do those
different learnings add to our
understanding of AI - not surprisingly
one on democracy and AI and information
and the way in which information is
transmitted and curated these days
through to things like defence and
security as well and then we've had two
workshops which have focused
specifically on health and a very
interesting one that's still to come up
on AI and the future of Arctic conflicts
so I think all of these efforts as you
can see they span many different
disciplines that were required in order
to to explore them but also where
grassroots led it was very important to
us that we do an open call that we go
out to the community and we make sure
that we were supporting the work that
was of interest to that community and
was going to bring them together
the second area of work that we did was
called AI futures policy labs and we did
this in partnership with the Brookfield
Institute for entrepreneurship and
innovation and these were facilitated
workshops that were held directly with
policymakers and they had two objectives
the first was to raise awareness and
understanding of AI so we reached into
our AI community of scientists and
chairs and held some AI 101 sessions
with policymakers and then we also had a
facilitated session where they could
explore what were some real-life use
cases in the world and what were the
potential implications for policy moving
forward and that work culminated with a
presentation to the International Open
Government Partnership summit last May
in a series of publications that have
emerged out of that work over time and
let me give you a sense of some of the
things that are coming up so in the AI
futures world we're very very happy to
be partnering with the BC Ministry of
Health to co-develop
a policy lab focused specifically on an
AI in the health care setting the one
that's going to happen is is going to
happen in February of this year it will
take place in beautiful Victoria and
we'll be exploring the question of how
AI is changing the nature of health care
what are the opportunities for improving
the well-being of citizens and what
considerations does government need to
be aware of we think about health data
we think about privacy we think about
applications and the rise of private
sector applications and technologies as
well so there are many really
interesting issues that we are are
hoping to dig into with the BC Ministry
of Health and then and then take that
work and explore it with some of the
other provinces in cities both within
Canada and elsewhere the second one I
want to make sure everyone in this room
is aware of is that we have this
fabulous partnership and continue to
work very closely with both France and
the UK and exploring the many societal
issues but we also wanted to make sure
that we engaged with our partner to the
south and so we reached out to the US
State Department and are going to be Co
funding a workshop with the US State
Department and with innovation science
and Economic Development Canada in
Ottawa to have a symposium directly
focused on the questions of economic
innovation there are
any of these there are many of these
that are very a lot of interest to the
community right now on both sides of the
border so we thought why not convene
some experts bring them together in the
style in which CFR does so economists
political scientists civil society
actors industry and government as well
so what we're going to do is we're going
to hold one day which will be a
invitation-only workshop this is CFR
style will bring together a group
they're going to explore how AI can be
leveraged for economic growth but what
and what conditions need to be fostered
in order to support the AI industry but
we'll also be looking at the societal
implications of AI deployments so what
is what does it mean in terms of labor
market distortions privacy security
equity and equality and fairness and so
we're really looking forward to a very
interesting day on the 15th and then on
the 16th we're going to have a public
forum and a public event whereby we'll
put together some of the panelists of
the experts that we're going to bring
together and reach out more broadly to
the community so if either of those were
of interest to you or if you happen to
be in Toronto on January 15th just reach
out we would very much like for for
everyone in this room to be to be a part
of that work and I can't we can't do
this without our partners so I did want
to take a moment to really thank CFS and
Antoine Patti
UK research and innovation on the call
that we did together
Brookfield Institute for innovation and
entrepreneurship who were so critical to
those early policy labs and we continue
to work with them moving forward of
course it all starts with the Government
of Canada and their investment is NASM
and our work closely with the Ministry
of Health here moving forward on the
policy labs and elsewhere and this very
interesting new partnership with the
State Department of course there are
many other partners who came on board
Microsoft Canada Microsoft Research ATV
financial element AI the World Economic
Forum and Rand and so we'll continue to
reach out and be in partnership with
them now we need to decide where we go
from here so we've we've held 15
workshops and we really do feel we have
catalyzed a community of interest and
the reality is is that it's very nice to
see that there is funding now moving
into this space that's true
actually exploring innovative social
science humanist and legal and economist
approaches to AI and its implications
and so now we're trying to figure out
where CFR will go next what is the next
evolution and we're starting to look
more closely at our c4 model and this
question of sustained support over time
to pull together these communities of
diverse perspectives and to focus those
on some potential solutions in this
particular space so watch this space
we'll know where we're going by the
spring I look forward to your advice
don't hesitate to reach out if if you
have any ideas for us and now it gives
me great pleasure to introduce the
keynote speaker for this afternoon
Candace archers Candace augers is a
professor of psychological science at UC
Irvine she is the co-director of our CFR
program and child and brain development
and she was on the leadership team that
put together a successful proposal
called generation AI Candace researches
how social inequalities and adversity
affect early child development and also
adolescent development and she has a
particular focus on new technologies and
how new technologies can offer intervene
interventions to provide support and
also their potential effects more
broadly within society as I said she was
a member of a prosol group including
Anna Goldenberg I'm not sure if Anna is
here today who's also a candidacy for
chair in AI Ronald doll at UC Berkeley
and Mitsuko Ito at UC Irvine who put in
a proposal to specifically explore how
AI technologies are affecting the health
well-being and development of children
and teenagers we held the first workshop
together with UNICEF and the World
Economic Forum last spring we followed
up with another workshop in Toronto to
dig drape directly into some of these
potential interventions in in Toronto
following on that and not only is she
exciting and fabulous to hear from and I
really I'm so much looking forward to
her talk and I know we're all in for a
treat
but she's also really trying to explore
but 10
connections in this space this is such
an emerging field there are so many
opportunities for technologists to come
together with child psychologists and
for new media experts and others to
explore potential intervention so I hope
if any of you are interested in hearing
more about her work I think she would be
very interested in connecting with you
too so Candace welcome well good
afternoon I'm glad so many people
returned after lunch this is good to see
I'm going to talk today about Generation
a I so it's difficult to name the
generation that's coming but one of the
thoughts is that this generation of kids
growing up and maybe your parents too
some of them is growing up amidst one of
the most rapidly changing digital
technological transformations that that
we have seen and this is bound to shape
how they see the world their experiences
and you'll see from the data that I
present there they're spending a lot of
time in the digital world and I think it
behooves us to think a little more
carefully about the kind of experiences
that they're having now this isn't just
here in Canada the US it's a global
phenomenon so 70% of the world's youth
are online in 104 countries over 80% of
youth are online
it varies of course by low to high
income status but even in low income
countries 30% of youth are online and
that's changing rapidly a figure that
got us thinking about this topic more
generally was the fact that one in three
Internet users are children but the
Internet and the algorithms that under
gritted were not designed with with
children in mind and we're seeing some
of the effects of that have that now now
just some quick stats these are data
from the United States
it's ranges from 2004 to 2008 eeen so a
decade ago my research team we started
to follow young people on their mobile
devices and when we would go into their
homes what we found is about 40 percent
of young people owned their own mobile
phone when we go in now close to eighty
five percent of young people between 10
and 15 have their mobile phone and it's
virtually universal so ninety four five
percent of adolescents have access to a
mobile phone
they're on them a lot they're constantly
connected so again parents in the room
this will not become as a surprise these
are the latest data from the u.s. tweens
that's your 8 to 12 year old spend 4.4
hours on some media screen time so this
is in addition to any time they're in
front of a screen for educational
purposes for homework and at school okay
teens so our 13 to 18 year olds are in
front of a screen for 7.2 hours a day
media screen time right now this if
you're counting it actually totals more
of the time they're in school so the
content that they're viewing isn't being
selected by experts in content creation
it's often being selected by the
algorithm personalization algorithms
that direct their attention and
personalize what they'll what they'll
see next right so this is a huge
opportunity for learning and some argue
that it's a risk for development now
something to keep in mind as we go
through when I talk a little bit about
the rationale for the generation AI
workshops is there's an equity issue
here as well so when we look at teens
and low-income households they spent on
average three more hours per day on
screens than their peers and higher
income households right and there's what
we call homework gaps they're doing
different things while they're online
again a huge opportunity for that
content to be to be shaped all right so
it's not just those US kids it's Canada
too right and so this is some data from
Canada and what you'll see is a fourth
graders I have one of these who's asking
me for a phone constantly and this was
about three years ago so 24% of fourth
graders have a smartphone and it
increases pretty rapidly now an
interesting thing when you ask kids
about social media account and these
again are higher now 30% of Facebook 16%
of Twitter and these are the ones that
kids don't actually use anymore right so
but the social media company their
policies right or they don't allow you
under the age of 13 right and so
everyone's turning a bit of a blind eye
with gvp are there regulations in the UK
it's becoming harder to do that and so
there's all kinds of issues around David
data privacy so of course the news story
reads that government survey confirms
that yes Canadian teens really like
their smartphones so there you have it
science says so alright so what's the
problem
right so the online world has not been
designed with youth in mind and we
taught you know you hear this all the
time conversations you have probably
with your own kids with your colleagues
everyone has an opinion about kids these
days and kids in a digital world and our
reaction to this immersion in the
digital world has been fear right we say
that they're addicted the phones are
making them depressed but they're
disconnecting them from the world
they're losing their skills they're
becoming victims right that's that's
what we hear that's all we see in the
headlines all the time so there's a
likening of time online to crack cocaine
there's a likening of phone use as
addiction so an interesting stat though
that we talked about last night actually
at dinner was at more adults actually
text and drive than kids so kids are
doing better than us on this there's a
argument in the neuroscience world that
smartphones are rewiring the brain we
don't know how but they're going to
change our brains and here in Canada
they've been blamed as they have in the
US for an uptick in a really serious
health problem which has been there's
been an increase in suicide and
depression among young people and people
are pointing at smart smart phones to
blame now the problem is that the facts
tell a really different story right so
this is the narrative that we've been
hearing in the media this is the
narrative that is compelling for many
people to believe that we might want to
believe but the facts tell a very
different story
in this and we've been tracing this for
about a decade because the parents that
come in with their teens into our lab
they want to know this is a whole new
world they weren't raised in this
context they don't have the answers to
what what their parents did with them so
we've surveyed come the large-scale
surveys of how adolescents use their
time online and their mental health our
own team and others track kids every day
on their mobile phones and their
wearable devices and try and understand
how time online influences things like
mental health sleep school performance
and then we've reviewed kind of
meta-analysis in the field and what can
I can tell you across all of these these
different types of evidence is there's
very little support for the narrative
that's out
that smartphones are to blame for the
problems we're seeing in our kids in
fact kids look really good today in
terms of Education in terms of falling
rates of violence and teen pregnancy
they're the most educated connected
generation we've seen they're doing well
in a lot of metrics right there's some
issues that have coming up and and we'll
deal with those as they come this is a
paper published in Nature human behavior
by some colleagues and what they did is
they took the data sets that have been
kind of the source of information for
people going on the nightly news talking
about cell phones destroying a
generation and they use specification
curve analysis essentially subjecting
the data to billions of iterations of
analyses and find essentially that when
there is an association it's tiny its
meaning of school it there's an
association that explains less than 1%
of the variance they put that in
contrast to other things in the data
like eating potato chips was a bigger
effect riding a bicycle was like 10
times as big and so there's been a lot
of fear but not a lot of support for for
this connection in in the big scale
surveys that we see we follow kids daily
on their mobile devices so this is the
state of North Carolina down at the
bottom and those are 2000 kids that
young people we've been following
between the ages of 10 and 14 and we
survey them three times a day people
thought the kids would get annoyed at
this and they wouldn't want to respond
but you ding a kid and they pick up
their phone and do something with it
like it's very Pavlovian right and so we
actually you know they respond to about
85% of the surveys we get a lot of data
from them and also streaming from things
like wearables and we look at this
question of whether kind of time online
daily has negative effects on symptoms
of depression anxiety things were really
worried about and we find no daily
linkages between technology and health
in fact we find the opposite effect it's
small but it's there on days that
adolescents may report better well-being
on days that they're more connected to
their friends right they're using their
devices to connect with you as their
parents to their friends they actually
feel better they're more connected with
the world so it's it's the opposite
message that were that we're hearing
this is my student
Mikey Jensen a new faculty member at UNC
that
that's done some of this work so we
wrote a commentary on this in in nature
and basically outline this issue which
served as the basis for the generation
AIA workshop which is that there's been
a lot of focus on kids in technology but
we seem to be looking at the wrong
things we're worried about smartphones
destroying our children of the digital
world harming kids when really the kids
seem to be mostly okay
there are some serious issues facing
young people today but this loss of
investment or this direction attention
that's directed at smartphones is really
distracting us from some of the bigger
issues around privacy around equal
access to opportunities in online world
right so I talked about that homework
gap there's no longer a gap in terms of
who has devices and our low-income
samples more low-income kids actually
have access to smartphones and those
tight-end social media so they're online
but their experiences are very different
the way that they're supported to
interact with the online world to ensure
that they're safe they're accessing the
right kind of content that looks very
different across youth from higher
versus lower income so we're seeing
these opportunity gaps in the same way
that we see them in offline spaces right
so children from lower-income households
are increasingly disengaging in kind of
sports activities having more of that
free time to spend online children in
the upper income brackets are over
scheduled have a wealth of opportunities
and in the online world we seem to be
seeing that as well so a rich get richer
phenomenon so the question is how can we
stop the conversation which is about
technology destroying a generation and
turn to productive solutions in terms of
shaping the online world in ways that
create equitable opportunities for all
kids ways that can take advantage of the
fact that they're on their devices for
the number of hours that we're seeing
we're seeing there so the solution was
your children aren't becoming digital
zombies but focusing on the fears versus
of facts could allow us to miss the real
causes of costly disorders like
depression anxiety distract us from
attention of real issues around kind of
privacy consent for young children
responsibilities of
to socialize children the digital age
many parents once kids hit eight or nine
and we don't really know what they're
logged in online we back up and we just
let let it take care of itself right we
think that we don't understand it
something else is going on there and and
the online world can just just take over
our kids will navigate themselves we've
never dropped them off on the street in
Vancouver and do the same thing and
there are missed opportunities for
innovation equity and intervention so
there are some really interesting and
great things happening in precision
medicine and mental in digital health
but when we review the literature in
these spaces what we find is that
adolescents are left out of these
research and development and left out of
the creation of products in this space
there are harder population to find you
often need to get to consents right so
from the parent and the adolescent so
they're often neglected in this space
and so the workshops came at a time
which allowed us as a community I think
to start to move from this fear-based
conversation towards evidence-based
actions to support youth in the digital
age so can we stop fighting the
narrative that the digital technology is
ruining this tech this generation and
can we start to build things that might
work or solve real problems that exist
in the digital world so Rebecca said
here's the team lucky to have to Canada
hey I chairs here and Anna Goldenberg
and Sarah Mustapha Vee and it's been a
really kind of wonderful way to kind of
talk across disciplines and figure out
where the the hotspots are in terms of
collaboration and where we can push
things forward as a group I'm just going
to give you an overview of the two
workshops that we hosted and the kinds
of questions we've been working on in
case they peak some interest here with
that being kind of the rationale for why
we wanted to go down this path
so I'm workshop one we had the
opportunity to partner with the World
Economic Forum and UNICEF who've been
doing work in the generation AI space
and there are three issues that you know
really surfaced during that workshop one
was at the both the time we held it
there was an open call for input on a
revision of the new copa so via online
privacy and protection for children laws
huge legislation in the United States
lots of big fights about this and the
base
Primus is to try and protect children
from advertising right but guess what
children don't know what commercials are
right so my kids we were on vacation one
day one summer and they had been
watching I their iPads and YouTube and
we actually asked watched real TV and a
commercial came on and they started to
screen because I thought someone had
changed the channel right I mean this
was foreign to them there'd be a
commercial marketing to them commercials
now are the YouTube families that they
follow with products placed in the
family right they're not the traditional
marketing to children that we have all
these laws and regulations bill for we
actually need the deep learning to
identify when our child is being
marketed to in the YouTube video of the
the influences that they're following
right so we can't even categorize what
the advertisement or marketing frame is
right now right so we need innovative
solutions in this space I told you that
you know adolescents are spending seven
hours on a day tweens are spending kind
of eight two or eight to thirteen year
olds are spending about four hours
online a day a lot of that's happening
on YouTube and we've heard a lot of
conversation about YouTube and their
personalization algorithms but this is
this is an interesting issue from a
child development perspective right so I
like personalized up Asian algorithms
when I when I need new shoes like an ad
pops up and it seems to know the kind I
usually buy at this time but I don't
know that we want our children being
targeted and pegged into content based
on what they've watched previously or
what someone and their family on their
iPad is watch we recently or what their
zip code says that children like them
watch recently so in terms of
reinforcement learning the Explorer
exploit space there's not a real match
between how we want children to learn in
online spaces the content we want
directed at them and what the algorithms
that are directing their content are
optimized for which is time on screen so
eyes on screen and so the question that
came up within this working group was
whether or not kind of child-friendly
algorithms could be developed that are
optimized
thing that's more
developmentally-appropriate versus
optimizing to more marketing goals the
last one was a issue that came up with
UNICEF that is something that they
struggled what they've been trying to
figure out how to apply different
principles of AI and innovation to
assist children around the world they've
been using facial recognition to
identify and map and real-time
malnutrition among children so that they
can distribute aid they had to shut down
this program because they also have to
store those images they have to get
children to consent to the use of those
images they couldn't risk in some
regions of the world having those images
labeled stored and not having the kind
of data infrastructure to support that
so here's an example where there's a
real innovation that could move food
that can move aid that had to be stopped
because we just haven't sorted out how
to protect children especially
vulnerable children in these spaces and
so this was more of a survey of kind of
what are the kind of big issues the
places where issues are on child
development around vulnerable
populations and their own AI touch and
we had a host of partners that were
there you know Sesame Workshop I'll
always go visit Oscar the Grouch right
um so that's been a fun partner to have
and then partners like Lego where the
most interesting thing from that group
was they designed for safety they said
listen we're we're not gonna risk
innovating in the digital space when our
kids stop playing with LEGOs we can't
really follow them because it's too
complicated it's too risky right to go
in and innovate in that space we know
how to do product safety is the brick
safe we're not really sure how to keep
the rails up in these digital spaces so
that brought us to workshop 2 which was
driven by a need to or a desire to want
to do something in this in this space
and workshop 2 was based on this insight
that essentially there's these
innovations that are happening in the
precision medicine the digital health
space when we review the apps and the
tools the agent-based assisted tools and
coach based tools that are out there
that are delivering things like
cognitive behavioral therapy or
evidence-based interventions it really
helped people on time of crisis what we
see is there's a lot of tools out there
there's actual
thousands of tools out there for adults
and for young children but there's
virtually nothing that's targeted
directly towards adolescents and we're
in the midst of seeing mental health
problems creep up among this population
emergency visits increase among this
population and we know from large-scale
surveys that youth are actually going
online to find out about their mental
health to search out solutions for
mental health but they go on line and
don't find kind of what they need in
those spaces so in Toronto I guess it
was just a few months ago we brought
together experts in implementation
science and adolescent development
technologists who developed here's one
example the ears which is a mobile
sensing tool that allows it is installed
in the phone that allows us to basically
track every keystroke that's being
entered into the phone to track location
to track kind of music preferences those
types of things and people are working
on trying to use that to predict women
to health onset or when something else
more severe might might occur so this is
this is some work we're starting to do
in this space Anna I don't think he was
here yet is doing some work with the
local emergency room and is wanting to
use the same tool in that context as
well
I'm putting the tool in the field to
track during the u.s. election to see
how kids are reacting to those kinds of
stressors in November so that will be
that'll be interesting so just to make a
case I think that you know in this
community those of you who are designing
algorithms to improve tools to building
the tools of the future many times young
people are really left out of this
equation they're hard to work with
they're complicated to work with but
it's so important they are early and
rapid adopters of new technology and
they are on in droves they are
constantly connected and we're about to
see the largest generation of young
people in human history come of age
right 1.8 billion so that's been that's
been phrase is both a big problem and a
big opportunity and so the balance
really is trying to find out how can we
build interdisciplinary teams how can we
build a digital space that produces more
equitable outcomes and help to close the
gap versus continue to amplify these
offline
in equities so with that I will close
out and I will take questions
[Applause]
I was just wondering I also have a grade
four son the kids that you are following
for your study how did they get chosen
to be part of the study
yeah and is that influenced the kind of
results you're getting yes that's a
great question so most studies prior to
this have really been selected and what
we did is we had the records for every
child that was enrolled in the state of
North Carolina public school system so
we took a random sample and we ensured
we had representation in terms of
socioeconomic status in terms of
ethnicity in terms of gender in terms of
the kinds of things household income the
kinds of things that would skew the
results so those are the kids that we
were able to follow for this study hi so
fascinating talk very interesting so I
was wondering did you was there output
of these workshops also some kind of
like guidance for the government to kind
of like legislate in these fields or it
was still speculative at this point yeah
so that was the that was one of the
goals with the Coppa feedback but I
think the whole premise is wrong so you
know one of these things when you start
to get into these conversation the law
is moving so slowly in these spaces
especially with respect to kind of
children that the conversation just
completely misses each other because if
we had the best science-based input
they're still not able to identify what
marketing is to kids they're still not
getting that it's a YouTube influencer
versus the standard cheerio commercial
right and that's like a fundamental law
MIT press is publishing kind of the
output of workshop one and it's along
with kind of invited contributions from
people to kind of scope the space and
we're hoping to have a social policy
person do a commentary at the end of
that but I don't think we're at the
point where we can kind of advise
specifically
well thank you first first of all for
very inspiring talk I also have two kids
and I completely agree about the data
you showed I have seven year old and
seven fifteen year old my question is
about the mental health and
possibilities for using AI to improve
mental health and use I was basically
curious if you might know of any like
Canadian companies or any kind of
organized efforts to develop apps or
online tools for kids and adults and
since they're gonna be online anyway to
develop such tools to guide them to
teach them to improve their mental
health in various ways I know there are
some startups in the US like war board
and so on but they mainly they're not
meant for kids specifically so what what
kind of efforts are being made in this
direction especially in Canada if you
know that's a great question so I would
say the first first point is on my
colleague Steven Schuler has a resource
which is called cyber guide and what he
does is he reviews every app that's on
the market that claims to improve mental
health right and the results are
actually really frightening both in
terms of how the data is handled on the
back end for security the effectiveness
of the app in general right and then
they monitor also level of engagement so
most people install the app and never
use it again right and so they've
there's this whole science of things
that we you know the most effective
thing is a coach based model which they
use the technology to enable and amplify
the evidence base but there are very few
we did a systematic review there are
very few that are targeting adolescents
which has to look a little different in
terms of privacy in terms of how they're
using peers for support in terms of how
they want to confidentially seek
information about mental health all kind
of questions around gender identity
sexual identity so I don't know if too
many companies are working in that
specific space there's an accelerator
you've killed second news in the u.s.
that's trying to push through
innovative kind of youth centered
programs but it's it's a moving target
if you if anyone knows of some I would
love to hear of the matter yeah yeah
really fascinating talk thank you very
much and and I think you you're raising
a very important questions like they
somehow the implicit implications of the
exposure to the media and and I think
it's very important to be aware that
there is though there are those implicit
implications that are not as
straightforward as they as porn or
advertising or so on but I think both on
the turn and the side of risks and
outside of opportunities you know it
seems like you need to interact with
professionals from other fields like if
someone is watching a movie who will
tell us if this movie can induce
depression or can enhance you know
awareness so some how are you
interacting with with a psychologist
with economists about what are the risk
factors or the opportunities that you
have to be concerned about yes I think
there's you know entire fields of kind
of media studies and communications and
you know study of psychology of media
exposure that's done some of this and so
we don't have to start from fresh I
think what's what's different is young
kids especially a very young age
becoming siloed in terms of their
content and exposure so who they see
what kind of representation they see of
the world how they think the world works
because of how the algorithms see them
right so how I'm gonna target the next
content based on kind of history of
viewing in my household and I think
that's the new part that we're seeing
now it's you know some it's like what
you're talking about this morning many
of the questions are old about kind of
media does violent media affect kids do
video you know we've been doing this for
a long time but there's something
different now as the exposure becomes
more personalized and what that means at
a very young age for children to have
that window into the world and for that
window to be unsupervised not to steal a
term from this community
more so in among the most vulnerable
populations
[Applause]